[Música]
a única pessoa que não deveria estar
aqui sou eu fui declarado morto no dia
11 de julho de 1983 e se comunicado com
uma tarja preta estava pregado no mural
da minha faculdade e dizia o seguinte a
universidade católica de petrópolis
comunica com pesar o falecimento do
aluno do curso de engenharia ricardo
trajano no desastre aéreo da varig
ocorrido em paris no dia 11 de julho
passado
a primeira notícia que não havia nenhum
passageiro sobrevivente nesse vôo era um
boeing 707 da varig que partiu do rio de
janeiro
faria uma escala em paris e chegaria ao
seu destino era londres
os jornais já tinham publicado a notícia
as rádios televisão e foi essa notícia
que a minha família recebeu uma tragédia
123 mortos e era desesperador porque meu
pai já estava encomendando meu
sepultamento e minha mãe por motivos não
naturais não acreditava mas como vocês
estão vendo eu não morrer
eu fui o único passageiro sobrevivente
desse vôo
eu costumo dizer que eu estou no lucro
no crédito dá vida a muitos e muitos
anos mas eu não apenas sobreviver
eu comecei a pensar muito sobre a vida
sobre os meus relacionamentos e
principalmente nos valores de vida
eu tinha 21 anos era minha primeira
viagem meu sonho era conhecer londres
o avião lotado o vôo tranqüilo
faltando cerca de cinco minutos para
chegar na escala em paris no aeroporto
de orly
eu estava sentado lá atrás lá no fundo
na penúltima fileira e atrás de mim
começou uma fumaça pequena na projeção
do toalete começar foi lá e eu por puro
instinto impulso
tirei meu cinto e fui andando pra frente
todos os passageiros permaneceram
sentados e quando cheguei lá na frente
lá não tinha ainda o menor sinal de
fumaça
o comissário chefe me viu me deu uma
bronca folgar o ato está fazendo em pé
cara só tava vendo que o avião está
chegando que é proibido se ficar aqui
volta imediatamente o seu lugar
olhei para a cara dele disse que não
estava falando comigo eu na verdade eu
subi e desci literalmente ordem dele o
transgredir e continuei andando
cheguei lá na frente de 12 comissários
na divisória da cabine em pé
desesperados gritando porque a fumaça
ela foi muito rápido já tinha tomado
conta de todo o avião estava lá na
frente também era uma fumaça negra preta
tóxica à densa fumaça de pneus queimando
sabe e quando fui ver os comissários
novamente não consegui vê-los muito
escuro e percebi que eles tinham parado
de gritar provavelmente já estava
morrendo e eu fiquei encostado na
divisória também não enxergava um palmo
na minha frente
parecia que eu estava debaixo da terra
ea mv a sensação da morte de um
flashback na minha cabeça aquele filme
em fração de segundos
eu me despedindo da vida meus amigos
minha família e sentia morte me
abraçando
neste momento o avião inclinou muito e
ele estava procurando na verdade um
coisa pra fazer porque se eles
continuassem até o aeroporto
provavelmente ele poderia explodir no ar
ea cabine de comando estava cheio de
fumaça também não enxergavam mais
instrumentos
aí de repente fizeram um pouso forçado
na plantação de cebolas e assim que eles
fizeram pose parar num avião eu apaguei
apaguei perdi os sentidos e o teto todo
do avião foi caindo em chamas
aquelas placas aquelas zelarem do avião
do teto foi caindo em cima de todas as
pessoas carbonizando todas as pessoas
queimam todas as pessoas e caiu uma
placa grande nas minhas costas estava
desacordado no sentir eu queria abrir
são parentes para contar uma coisa
há uns anos atrás encontrei um amigo meu
ele tem um lado espiritual fortíssimo
ele lê muito e é um cara fora da curva
ele queria saber se momentos de aflição
que eu passei eu falei há pouco pra
vocês e falei puxa eu sentia morte me
abraçando e falou ricardo não era a
morte de abraçando cara era vida te
proteger abraço emocionado
falei cara eu fiquei esses anos todos
pensando na morte me abraçando você vem
aqui me desmonta e fala pura realidade
cara da vida me protegendo
que coisa mais linda e aí o de entrada
no hospital
cheguei no hospital sem opa e me
confundiram com um comissário sérgio
balbino meu porte físico era muito
parecido quando ele então eu era o
sérgio balbino eo ricardo tinha morrido
a primeira notícia foi que o brasil foi
essa minha família desesperada
minha mãe era a única que acreditava que
o rodrigo
e aí eu fiquei 30 horas em coma
nesse período todo que eu fiquei em coma
é eu uma letra pedir um uma folha de
papel e uma caneta e eu desacordado uma
letra tremida de criança
coloquei o nome do meu pai telefones
o endereço é o psycho grafia esse
bilhete estava desacordado
quero pegar os bilhetes foram na lista
de braço de tripulantes não achava meu
nome for uma lista de passageiros apenas
para dar uma checada
de repente vi meu nome lá e cá trajando
como como que esse cara passageiro
estava lá na frente junto com os
comissários
os passageiros todos sentados mortes nas
poltronas imediatamente a varig liga pra
casa
olha nós queremos comunicar que seu
filho meu pai atendeu o telefone
nós queremos com nehme comunicar que seu
filho está mal mas está vivo
gente de um velório que estava em casa
virou uma grande festa
minha mãe levantou do sofá apontou pra
todo mundo falou não falei que meu filho
estava vivo
cara eu acordei depois dessas 30 horas
que estava em coma acordei no hospital
não entendo absolutamente nada
todo entubado sentindo muita dor nas
costas
olhei para as minhas costas toda
queimada minhas nádegas e nas coxas tudo
queimado
a primeira reação que eu tive foi olhar
para as minhas mãos colocar a mão no
rosto para ver se estava queimado
examinar meu amigo aqui olhei levantei
tava tudo bonitinho no lugar falei
rabelo leza gente beleza na hora
me soa tão lírico foi tão espontâneo
sério que foi um momento inicial de todo
um pensamento uma energia positiva que
caminharam comigo ao longo de toda a
minha difícil e lenta recuperação
quanto ao meu estado de saúde os médicos
não me dava uma semana de vida
a minha primeira radiografia como se
fosse um atestado de óbito radiografia
de pulmão
mas desde os primeiros dias de
internação e já muito debilitado
eu procurava extrair naquele dentro
daquele ambiente pensado conturbado que
eram ct as coisas boas que me rodeavam
eram coisas aparentemente banais mas
carregadas de uma força de energia de
otimismo que me alimentava enormemente e
que me davam força para lutar pela vida
que parece está próxima do fim
e essas coisas eram coisas com meus pais
faziam cartazes diziam frases escritas
com caneta pelo entregava para a
enfermeira não pôde entrar você tem
enfermeira mostrar aquelas traz pra mim
vamos lá regado força ricardo ricardo
você vai sair dessa
frases bobas na verdade mas que pra mim
ali naquele momento eram frases cheias
de energia fé e esperança
quero ficar esperando todo santo dia ela
chegar com uma frase dessa diferente
para mim ficar contando as horas no
relógio era meu alimento
da mesma forma as cartas que eu recebi a
receber cartas meus parentes meus amigos
do mundo inteiro cartas pessoas que eu
não conhecia me mandando força e as
fitas cassetes sabe que a fita cassete
pa pb pré-histórico aqui eram fitas que
você tinha que se ouvia música som e tal
e eu tinha um gravador cassete mas eu
não podia ouvir tava no meio de ct i e
ii e teve a idéia de pegar os ternos
estetoscópio colocar ele aqui ea boca
dos cantores pop colocar um gravador e
ficava ouvindo música dos amigos joules
tons a índia ei
cara eu só lamento que uma coisa não tem
tido a idéia de ter patenteado e se um
evento eu fui o inventor do golpe -
hospitalar de todas essas coisas que eu
falei pra você agora pra vocês eu chego
à conclusão que nós somos seres
essencialmente simples a nossa natureza
simples importa o quanto você tem o
quanto você é você vê aquele cara pra
você fala pô meu amigo você sabe com
quem você está falando não vale nada
absolutamente nada nos momentos mais
difíceis importantes da nossa vida
a simplicidade é tudo a nossa essência é
simples e aí passado que três meses
hospitalizado
foi um processo lento e gradual
emagrecer cerca de 15 quilos
seis meses depois eu tinha voltado para
a faculdade e jogando basquete e o mais
importante não ficar com nenhum tipo de
sequela mas me faltava única coisa
terminar a minha viagem foi interrompida
e aí como bom ariano teimoso e cabeça
dura como eu sou um ano depois eu voltei
na mesma agência da varig
cheguei para atendente falei olha eu
gostaria de uma passagem para londres
com escala em paris a mulher mandou o
preço logo imediatamente falei 'não não
se não tá entendendo
sabe aquele acidente que teve um ano
atrás
sobreviveu apenas um passageiro os
passageiros ou eu
você não acha que a varig
eu paguei a minha passagem cash e volta
para a vaga não cheguei na primeira
escala da ida
você não acha que a vale que tinham da
passagem
ela revelou os olhos filme foi você me
deu um abraço supercarinhoso eu sei que
minutos depois já estava com a passagem
no bolso vai me deu outra passagem no
dia do embarque embarque com um grande
amigo meu
maurício valladares e avaí que soube que
nós vamos embarcar imediatamente nos de
um upgrade não é isso que vocês falam
uma primeira classe e aí já dentro do
avião
ele se viu pra gente isso avião levantar
vôo e serviu pra gente
whisky caviar champanhe vinho e nós
tomando todas quando o avião decolou
o abc o maurício já mamadú calibrado
falou pra mim o ricardo é o seguinte se
você levantar daí mesmo que foi no
banheiro eu vou atrás de você a gente de
todos esses estudos
essas estatísticas que eu vejo a
probabilidade de acontecer um acidente
aéreo é mínima é de um acidente para
cada 3 milhões de vôos ou seja eu pego
uma pessoa coloca para viajar todos os
dias dentro do avião ela vai precisar de
8.100 anos para que aconteça um acidente
com ela mas eu estava não desse vôo que
as pessoas me perguntam algumas por
ricardo me destino eu prontamente
respondeu falando gente o destino
nós construímos nosso destino cara eu
escolhi minha passagem escolher
companhia aérea escolheu o dia do vôo
escolheu o lugar foi vital para mim uma
sucessão de coisas do qual eu fui
protagonista quero dizer pra você meu
amigo
não adianta você ficar em casa de braços
cruzados esperando a vida sabe acontecer
alguma coisa o la numa praia debaixo de
um lindo coqueiro esperando as coisas
caírem do céu mas contraria um coco na
sua cabeça
e as pessoas que acreditam que o destino
já está traçado gente elas olhem para os
dois lados antes de atravessar a rua
portanto eu não me vitimismo jamais me
vitimizem de um pensamento que eu adoro
que diz o seguinte nunca se dê por
vencido
porque quando você pensa que tudo acabou
é o momento de tudo recomeço e muito em
cima disso eu tenho certeza absoluta que
é possível que começarmos a vida após
uma queda literalmente que aconteceu
comigo após um trauma após o fracasso
até mesmo após uma perda eu ricardo vivo
o presente passado pra mim já foi já era
não volta mais
o futuro não sei que vai acontecer não
sei que quando você manhã comigo eu
achava que a felicidade é a minha
felicidade estava lá junto com o futuro
eu comecei a perceber a felicidade minha
felicidade aqui que era aqui nesse
momento aqui dentro de mim ser feliz
o réu ter uma vida perfeita quase que
perfeita
felicidade é só questão de ser quando eu
estava no hospital eu procurava tomar o
melhor remédio todos os dias a minha
super dose diária quero-quero aqueles
cartazes os meus pais aquelas fitas
aquelas cartas ou canalizado aquilo tudo
por um pensamento só eu vou sair daqui
eu tenho que sair daqui sabe pra que eu
queria para dar um abraço e um beijo
as pessoas que mais amava era isso é o
meu combustível de vida
será tudo para mim hoje eu já sou 16 em
tal eu era engenheiro civil agora sou
engenheiro se vira trabalho com o
comércio tem que matar um leão todos os
dias mas não desisto procuro manter o
foco tem atitude e tocar essa vida gente
essa vida que isso aqui é um grande
palco show grande palco nós somos os
atores
eu ia adorar saber se dois atos
um proposta interpretar outro tudo isso
é a ea ser ótimo né mas a cortina que
era só se fecha uma vez e acabou o
espetáculo a nossa edição limitada e
avisa para aquele senhor gosta de botar
o dedo na frente falar você sabe com
quem você está falando lembra revisa pra
ele que ele não leva nada dessa vida
muito menos a sua arrogância
eu queria contar um caso que me marcou
muito e me emocionou muito caso recente
foi com relação à minha mãe é aquela
velha guerreira sempre acreditou que
estava vivo mas faleceu há dois anos e
meio atrás
aos 96 anos de idade lúcida até o fim e
nos últimos dois meses de vida dela
passou no hospital ela morava no rio
mora em belo horizonte sempre que podia
ia lá visitá la em uma das últimas vezes
que estive com ela ela chegou pra mim e
me deu um beijinho me despedir eu falei
ela só assim ricardo vai embora não
quero falar uma coisa para você que eu
nunca falei na época do seu acidente
falei que fui mãe é o seguinte naquele
período que as pessoas não te dá uma
semana de vida eu tinha que arrancar o
seu pai do hospital do do quarto do
hotel nós pegávamos do metrô
nós vamos visitar todos os dias assim
que nós saltamos do metrô
nós vamos fazer uma longa caminhada céu
azul verão e o sol iluminando minhas
mãos o tempo todo o tempo todo eu ia
andando o tempo todo som dominando
minhas mãos
chegando no hospital fechava minhas mãos
e chegando mais próximo de você abriria
e transmitir a toda essa energia para
você
gente eu sei que dia do quarto chorando
aos prantos mas com a certeza absoluta
que toda essa energia me acompanha até
hoje e para o resto da minha vida
obrigado
[Aplausos]
o tom